foreign
oh i didn't see you there
i don't know why i felt the need to do
that cheesy nonsense but
there we go let me actually pull this
a little closer so i can see the chat
better there we are
and a good day to all of you i hope
you're having a nice week so far i hope
you had a nice weekend
it was my birthday on sunday as you
might have
guessed from the uh from the name of the
live stream
oh that's lovely
[Laughter]
thank you ms wicked wolf much
appreciated
can't say on due to rehearsals one
wanted to wish you a belated happy
birthday thank you castiel
that looked like some good cake yes it
was quite good
it goes well with raspberries
uh what did you do to celebrate uh
not much you know
the plague is still ongoing
ah um but you know i got to i got to be
with liz which was
um always nice uh she made me
a lovely dinner and we also did you know
take out
at other points in the weekend we
actually did uh see some friends
but you know staying six feet away
and with mass and all that i miss
hugging people
i really really do but it was still
really nice
to to see folks um a few at least
so that that was what i did i mean it
was it was a laid back
birthday by necessity
has anyone ever given you a lap dance or
vice versa
um
i don't i don't
think i've ever like been given
what i would consider to be a proper lap
dance
because in my mind just like somebody
grinding on your lap for two seconds and
then giggling and wandering off that's
not a lap dance
uh that's not even a tease but uh
i don't think i've had a proper lap
dance
have i ever given one
not for free
thank you very much logan happy birthday
you beautiful being you ah thank you
um in the past i've sort of done a thing
about
unboxing and going on about stuff that
people sent to me um
there's gonna be a little of that here
um
not it's not gonna be as much the
emphasis for a couple of reasons partly
because
i haven't checked my post office box
since
thursday last week so there may be stuff
that has arrived that
i haven't even gotten yet so there's
that
um in addition to that stuff has been
coming all month and i haven't
consolidated it in one place and i also
didn't wait on opening it so there's no
unboxing
i've opened everything as soon as i've
gotten it it's been a hell of a year
so you know i think i deserve that
at the very least um but there are a few
things that i will
probably highlight as time goes on
though if you follow me on tik tok
you've seen
some of these already my friends said
that you have muscular arms i
really don't but thank you
new patreon perk lap dances
i'd have to figure out what the um
support tier would have to be for that
i think i'd have to open up a new one
for that
it uh it would be on the higher end
but i'm worth it
i'm almost 40 and i'm
joking about giving lap dances
[Laughter]
thousand disney plus and theater joint
release dates announced today
okay
like i kind of assumed they were gonna
have to pull that trigger eventually
anyways
i mean disney was gonna put it off for
as long as they possibly could warner
brothers
you know caved sooner but disney
disney just holding out makes it seem
like it was much more
we don't have a choice whereas warner
brothers when they initially announced
that after not consulting with
any of their business partners they just
pissed everybody off
all disney had to do was hang back
what's your favorite movie from your
birth year 1982 of my math is right your
math
is right and
probably blade runner
there's some good ones from that year
though
uh i trolled you on twitch remember that
yes
yes ms wicked wolf i i've uh
i've noticed i see you
i see you
can you recite the rules of fight club
i don't talk about that
not e.t i like tt a lot as a kid but i i
kind of grow out of it i never had as
much
nostalgia for that one as i did for some
other stuff that i grew up on
there's professional dominatrix in
france who's over 80 years old so don't
worry about age
oh yeah i'm not implying that people of
a certain age can't engage in sex work
of course they can
i'm just sort of saying it's it's it's
just
funny to me this is not what i would
have thought my life was
at damn near 40.
uh at least you know there's more than
one reason for
death on the nile being pushed back to
february gives them time to reshoot all
the scenes that featured a certain actor
oh
i didn't realize that i'd see i hadn't
been following death on the nile
so i didn't know that there was somebody
in there that they were gonna have to
work around so i actually hadn't even
been following that
uh snyder calling out geeks and gamers
kind of makes me want
to be a fan of his now uh i actually do
i do want to talk about that uh a little
bit
uh reminder i try and keep up with the
chat but the only thing that will
guarantee i'm gonna catch your
um what you say is a super chat which
will also get you a heart and my
personal thanks so that
whole thing which quick recap if people
don't know
um either don't know the context or
don't know what happened
so geeks and gamers gamers
geeks and gamers is
quite frankly one of the most toxic
fan collectives on social media
in terms of just the amount of vitriol
that they spew
ostensibly they are anti-sjw
but um as with a great deal of people
who
claim that as their core position they
express a great deal of
misogyny of racism of
just a lot of nasty nasty nasty stuff
that comes out of that group and
they um were involved in
the raising of money for i believe it
was suicide prevention
uh which zack snyder was on a live
stream leading up to or maybe it was
even the same day as the release of
the of his cut the snyder cut of justice
league
on hbo max and he said on the live
stream
you know the logo for geeks and gamers
is on this stream but i want to be very
clear that we do not associate with them
and and there is no room for hate
in this fandom basically calling them
out
on the live stream they were hosting
with two of the members of that group
on the stream with him
it was a boss move uh
and i actually have a lot of respect for
it especially given the fact
that while i
i'm not going to say that snyder
intended for this to be the case but
let's be perfectly honest
he benefited from
pushes from groups like that a lot of
collectives and fan movements
like geeks and gamers backed the idea of
release the snyder cut
for a variety of reasons but
i have to respect him for basically
biting the hand that fed him
he i i cannot imagine that he's not
aware
he was on their stream he he can't be
unaware that
a lot of those kinds of people were
in the fan base that helped get the
snyder cut released
but he still felt it was important to
call out who they were and the kinds of
things they did
i i was i was kind of really
pleasantly surprised by that and i'm
i'm thinking about i might try and
tackle this
um next month sort of
diving into you know how much how much
responsibility
does a creator or an ip holder
have towards um
their fan behavior like do they have a
responsibility to
speak out how often does it actually
happen that they do
what tends to happen when they do i it's
something i'm looking into and i may do
a video on that
um but yeah that was that was an
interesting moment
from logan davis my take on zack
snyder's justice league specifically the
cyborg scene
where he's learning his powers i feel
like the message is
he has to try and resist the temptation
yeah which was kind of my big problem
with that scene
by putting all the emphasis on the power
he has
and putting at the forefront
of that the idea of how important it is
that he resists
doing horrible things the way that that
frames him as a hero
is it frames the act of not
being a monster as in
itself heroic and then
further extrapolates the idea of
the normal people should just be
grateful if he doesn't do all these
terrible things
which is not a perspective on
superheroes and definitely not a
perspective on real world people in
power that i
share at all but is one that
snyder has definitely played into in the
past
so like that whole thing really kind of
spoke to the heart of my
philosophical issues with the snyder cut
as a film as i said in my review i
actually think it's pretty good and it's
probably the best
version of itself
that it was ever going to be i don't
think we'll ever get a better version of
that
kind of thing to be
completely blunt about it but um
he he put together something that was
very true to his heart and very true to
his
um perspective and he made i think a
pretty good
although it's interesting something i
realized today
i think a big part of why i was more
prepared to go with it
is because i knew it wasn't going to
dictate the direction of future movies
so what that meant was i could treat it
like an elseworlds
whereas before if it had come out if if
if the whole thing hadn't happened if he
hadn't left the project if whedon hadn't
directed the latter half of it
and he had just gotten to finish his
version it wouldn't have been exactly
what we just got in the snyder cup but
even if it was
i probably wouldn't have liked it nearly
as much because i would have known in
the pit of my stomach
god i'm gonna have to watch a bunch more
movies just
like this realizing that it's
effectively a one-off
made me better able to appreciate it
because i didn't have to dread
what was next or that i don't know how
much more of this i want even if it's
good so being able to treat it like in
else worlds just did
wonders for my mindset in terms of
watching that
uh what do you think of the tone of
falcon and the winter soldier so far my
dad's first reaction
when watching it oh no please don't be a
drama i mean
i i feel like it's too early to settle i
don't think we're
truly gonna know what the tone is until
the two of them start interacting with
each other
um hi there kyle
it's i'm i'm getting used to uh
to members um and and the notices that i
get from that because yes
youtube memberships are a thing and
turned on and ghoster's having a lot of
fun with the uh
emojis i need to come up with some more
of those
thank you aaron oh my goodness thank you
very very much aaron oh
says happy post birthday have a drink to
celebrate our super arcade on my
birthday this friday
cheers
probably age badly and have not seen for
years but tootsie is 1982 that's right
it was i haven't rewatched that in a
long time either
because my memories of it are pleasant
enough and yes i suspect
probably hasn't aged uh particularly
well
one of my friends said that if you try
hard enough you can get the ass
to twerk anyone can twerk it if they try
hard enough
my issue with twerking is not an ability
is not an
inability to uh to get my ass to move
that way
it's the fact that i have a bunch of
other stuff that ends up flopping around
unless i'm
in like a gaffe and i really
prefer not to wear them anymore so you
know
it's uh there's other issues as the
great fran drescher would say happy 29th
birthday
lahayam
if you have the season 14 doctor who
blu-ray box set
i don't i i'd highly recommend the
documentary on elizabeth sladen that's
on there
really good look at her and a touching
tribute oh that's it's just nice to hear
that it's there
uh oh yeah so okay so this is death on
the nile it has
features a certain actor who has had
very similar
serious allegations against him his
initials are
ah
i did not remember that he was
gonna be in that oh
[Music]
oh god i'd actually almost completely
forgotten about him
we should all be so lucky
oh do you think who framed roger rabbit
aged well
yeah part of the benefit for who framed
roger rabbit
is it's already a period piece
so while that's not a blanket excuse
it does mean that to a certain extent
some of its more antiquated things
like say the depiction of jessica rabbit
and the
uh sexualization of that character can
be chalked up to the tropes of noir
which is playing with
and also sort of the position of
sexual power dynamics in the 19 what is
it 30s
in which it's set so
you know that helps it doesn't remove
that completely but honestly that helps
quite a bit
also fun fact the backstory for cyborg
they used is his new 52 origin
i'm not shocked i mean
a lot of the a lot of the newer stuff
has been pulling from
the new 52 or more recent origins and i
don't
i don't know why
literally nothing good came out of the
new 52
yes yes i'm standing by that nothing
there is no
good thing that came out of the new 50
tune fight me
i'm not in a position to fight i refuse
i read like a handful of things only one
of which didn't completely piss me off
but i still had issues with them
principle
and then i just never read it any of it
it was garbage
and i stand by that uninformed opinion
thank you very much
[Laughter]
who framed roger rabbit is 1947. okay so
i i knew it was the tail end of a decade
i just had the wrong one
um
court of owls of professor pig came out
of new 52
court of owls is garbage
i hated the court of owls
it was so bad oh
it started out with a lot of promise but
it
was trashed that story
it squandered what little potential it
had
so quickly it was really bad
professor pig
even if i admit to liking professor pig
or rather
liking the version of him that i saw in
gotham i'm not going to say the new 52
was worth it for that
what viewpoints would you be sympathetic
to if they didn't come from figures
uh like ben shapiro or steven crowder
at
i don't know how to begin
approaching that question i don't mean
that to be a jerk i'm not saying that
like how dare you ask me i don't even
know how to talk to you like i don't
the the simple fact is largely for
reasons of self-preservation in my own
mental health
i don't interact much
with people who hold those kinds of
positions
for my own sake because it's not good
for me
to hear that stuff spouted
and i actually kind of consider crowder
worse
than shapiro because shapiro
as distasteful as i find him at least
seems to understand at least slightly
the gravitas of what it is he's
trying to do or say or the ways in which
he's trying to
um shape thought
whereas crowder falls back on this very
misplaced idea that he's somehow a
comedian
so he'll say or do something
awful or demonstrably clearly
wrong and laughing on be like uh
just kidding bro like i
i never want to hear ben shapiro speak
but i have a tendency to kind of hope
that a piece of lighting equipment will
fall and hit stephen crowder in the head
while he's speaking there's your
difference no i'm not wishing
severe harm or death i'm just saying
it evokes a slightly different reaction
have you seen davis's videos i might be
doing a commentary track for him that'll
be
soon on youtube oh that's great i've
seen some of his stuff
um i keep meaning to go through like the
backlog
of his things and i i haven't really
gotten around to it
um you know what's
here's here's what's funny i'm sorry
going back to that earlier question i'm
kind of hung up on it now
apologies this is going to get mildly
political
i really have gotten to a point where
the presentation style or whatever
background knowledge i have about the
person who's speaking
i'm not going to say it doesn't matter
or that it doesn't
affect my opinion
of a speaker
but
i have gotten to a point where i zero
in on the core idea like it's just what
my brain does at this point
it borrows as hard as it can
through what are the past the words that
they're saying to what is the idea that
they are
that they are actually pushing
what is the actual core concept that
is at the heart of these words and when
i do that
i can get angry regardless of who's
speaking
uh in the discord actually earlier today
i watched a video that
somebody had um put a link to
on the subject of cancel culture and uh
the person being interviewed about it
was a
professor and he um
i'm taking his word for this but he
claims to have a
generally liberal progressive
general framework and point of view but
he still took issue with
cancel culture now assuming that he was
being honest about
the bulk of his political beliefs which
i don't have a reason to believe he
wasn't
regardless of that and you know that
would put him
and i in agreement or probably a great
number of things
but i i plowed right past that to look
at the core of the words of what he was
actually saying
and i got really pissed
at this guy he infuriated me
i wanted to shout at him because
his argument was garbage and his core
ideas that he was pushing were
not helpful at best
so the idea of
these ideas coming to me from a more
agreeable voice
a more agreeable vessel
i'm at a point where i don't think
that's gonna make a big
difference
it's took it's taken me a while
39 years to develop the level of
[ __ ] detector that i've got but i
think it's pretty good at this point
i just i just yeah
kind of want someone to burn crowder's
house down in
minecraft nobody has to actively burn it
let's let's just all uh
so i'll just do a little drum circle and
uh and pray to the creepers that they'll
come and blow it up
my mom and i were talking about the
bathroom bill oh god
she asked me what if a man lies and says
he identifies as a woman just to sneak
in to molest them
was that transphobic oh boy
okay so th this is uh
apparently this is where we're going
tonight uh
so
the argument which she is making
is a transphobic argument
so that is not me saying that your
mother
is transphobic she may well not be
but she is parroting a transphobic
argument
because the idea of going into the
bathroom to molest people
is already a crime
so the idea of what she's saying
is that we can't allow trans people into
the correct bathroom
because somebody might come in to do
something that we would
already persecute prosecute them for
and press criminal charges for
what it
basic it fails basic logic
just the idea that and this was
something
jessie brought up in the video that she
made on um
on the transgender athletes issue
when your proposed solution
to something restricts the rights of a
group
it is on the onus for you
to prove that that is necessary
but the way that bathroom bills work
is that it postulates a
possible thing that might happen no
record of it happening that i have
ever been able to find and says well
because that might happen
we have to prevent trans people from
going into the correct bathrooms
so for the sake of a theoretical bad
outcome
that has no evidential backing
they wish to engage in the factual
definite
disenfranchisement and belittling
of a group they want to definitely take
these rights away
because if they don't these rights of
someone else
might have a thing my there might be an
issue
you don't or you shouldn't you shouldn't
be able to definitely take rights away
from one group
because of what might happen elsewhere
if you can't substantiate
what you claim is going to happen you
have no business taking away people's
rights
and yes the right to pee in the bathroom
that you that matches your identity is a
right
and is a freaking safety issue
because you know what there's a hell of
a lot more evidence for there's a hell
of a lot more evidence
of trans women being beaten and raped in
men's rooms
than there are of men claiming to be
women molesting young
girls
your mother is not transphobic however
she is parroting turf
arguments she is parroting their talking
points
and my recommendation
is to try to politely inquire
where it is she picked up that argument
and she may not know
it may just be something that's
saturated in the environment and the
people she hangs out with so she may not
know
but i would be very concerned about
what else she's picking up from wherever
it is
that she got that
so
[Laughter]
always fun oh thank you
jimmy jonathan lee thank you very very
much
um happy post birthday you are always
young
in spirit well hope so
because i'm still working way more hours
than i should be so
i hope that holds
don't worry i called out my mom on it
i'm glad to hear that
um you know i said i was going to talk
about some of the stuff i got sent
for my birthday uh i got sent
a few pins uh
from uh someone this is
badge wolf is the maker on these so
we've got um
13th doctor and also
fifth doctor yeah you probably couldn't
see that with the glare but you know is
what it is i'm doing my best
ah i also this came
yesterday i got a tardis key this was
off my amazon wish list which was quite
nice
uh have you seen the tom baker story the
mask of man dragora i have not seen that
one yet
i think it's an underrated gem a great
mix between hartnell historical and
hinchcliffe and holmes gothic horror hmm
interesting
one thing about santa clara i never
could stomach all the damn vampires oh
lost boys that's a fun movie
how much water has she had so far
hmm quarter of a glass
the fear-mongering and think of the
children is just manipulative yeah it is
and and here's something that i
i i realized this a couple years ago and
i keep
uh coming back to it especially
when it comes to talking about people's
rights
anything that amounts to a slippery
slope argument
is a coward's argument
and a [ __ ] tactic
because when you make the slippery slope
argument which is what is
always deployed in these cases
it's what the bathroom bills are it's
oh well if you allow this
then what's to stop this happening this
will lead to
that when there's no evidence for it
or when one of the arguments and like if
you're younger you may not
know any of this but i swear to god this
was true
one of the arguments against allowing
gay people to marry and allowing that to
be legal was
well how will we stop what happens next
how will we stop people from marrying
dogs
the slippery slope argument is a way to
avoid actually talking about
the morality and the validity of the
thing at issue
when you make a slippery slope argument
you are instead
inventing a later thing
that most people would agree well that's
definitely bad and then you argue
against that but you're arguing against
something that
hasn't happened and isn't what
is being argued the only time
the only time that anybody should ever
be allowed
to get away with making a slippery slope
argument is when
they can cite precedent when they can go
okay look something very very similar
happened in this and it resulted in x so
i think we should talk about that
that i will make allowances for
especially because
that's something that comes up in a lot
of economic arguments because
you know what if they're gonna keep
arguing that the rick should get
tax breaks i'm gonna cite decades of
freaking economic precedent
about how that hasn't helped i'll talk
slippery slope then because i can look
at the slope we've already slid down
this far and go yeah no we already know
that doesn't work
but unless you can cite precedent and by
pressing i don't mean a single instance
i mean a reliable pattern that
demonstrates
when x happens y then also later happens
unless you can do that
slippery slope arguments have no
business in good faith discourse
of course it's not a good faith argument
99 times out of 100 but
you know if you're trying to have a good
faith argument
don't use slippery slopes please
whoops
[Laughter]
vera being eloquent gets me hot am i
eloquent
i just get worked up and lose track of
my own mouth
do you see the time lords as genderless
and non-binary and
uh by the way happy birthday um
i yes and no
what i tend to think of the time lords
of is that
gender just isn't
part of how they perceive themselves at
all because even someone who's
non-binary and genderless they would
have an understanding that well
you know there's this thing and i'm
separate from that i just think it
it's so nebulous and unimportant to them
i don't think he even registers
for that it you know i made the
comparison before it would be like
um you know getting hung up on
somebody's eye color
and the inherent validity of brown eyes
over blue or what have you like
well no who would do that and i think
that's probably about
that's probably about as far as time
lords
consider gender it's like oh you're that
okay cool
and like otherwise it just doesn't
matter it especially doesn't matter if
you consider
the um the looms to be canon which i
don't
but you know some people do thank you
very much
cara thank you you get a heart
and oh i'm not sure i'm go
all right i will try i'm going to try
i'm going to butcher this
um she wrote out happy birthday and
irish so
la breth sana duit
i can provide phonetic pronunciation if
needed i
i mean just let me know how badly i
butchered it and we'll leave it at that
uh that's uh that's good enough for me
uh but what if people are nice to each
other then other people will be nice to
each other and then everyone's being
nice to each other that's a slippery
slope
argument i like but unlikely i mean
honestly
there are um forces who would argue that
that would be terrible and people should
not all be
nice to each other because that would
put the world out of whack and destroy
the hierarchy
and some people really depend on the
hierarchy
which bond film will you review next um
so uh the next bond film
that i've actually i've already watched
and i've shot the review for
i need to edit it is
uh on her majesty's secret service
and i'm not going to spoil what my
opinion opinion
opinion on that one was the review will
be out on the break room
later this week
la breha shana gwich
okay
so mild butchering on my part then
destroy the hierarchy yes yes
hierarchies in general are
just not good they just aren't
happy birthday and thank you very much
for being sorry for creating great
content
that cheers me up when i'm feeling down
as an artist i want to draw all the
doctors which
doctor should i draw first whichever one
you feel
pulled towards i would think that um
four or thirteen probably lend
themselves to
um to some of the the easier art just
because
you know they're easy to sort of segment
out you know before you've got the hat
scarf um you know 13's got the
you got the rainbow across the chest and
yeah i mean that
as a non-artist i don't know what the
hell i'm talking about don't listen to
me
don't listen to me on recommendations
for how to do
art and drawing because i
do not know what i'm talking about
my daughter is a much better artist than
i am which she is very quick to point
out to me
on a regular basis she is nine
are you reviewing live and let die no
i am not i i got commissioned for one
movie from each bond era
live and let die is not the roger moore
that is on the docket
you look like susan with a long sleeve
tee and the
uh and the tardis key oh thank you liam
thank you for the sanity i offer sanity
wow that's that's a frightening thought
that is
ghostbusters is to you what roger rabbit
is to me oh fair
listen to a big finish about the daleks
using a plague to destroy earth
and they're running out of doctors
bad choice is that a recent big finish
or is that an older one
oh oh you mean bad choice of stories to
listen to
i i get i get
yes uh it's it's true bacasta
we live in a society
don't we batman
the slippery slope uh is if everyone has
rights and equal
social status the easier it is for the
working class to unify against the rich
basically
yeah am i the only one who reversed you
by your last name
um you might be i don't know i haven't
been keeping
track uh i really hope they didn't ask
you to review the worst more film
depends what's the worst more film
i know what i think it is i'm curious as
to what you think it is
i'm going to show some more stuff off i
got sent a couple of
um shades of green lipstick
i've sent um a brighter shade this one's
a darker
matte which i'm i'm looking forward to
using at some point because yet
even without my slytherin gear i will
find a way to
um uh
wear green lipstick regardless i just
realized pseudonym
i didn't give you a heart for the super
chat
so there's that for you uh
i giggle when you said i see you you
know how much i love to troll you but i
do it out of love
i know i know moon wreck oh yeah moon
moon rikers terrible moon maker is not a
bond film moonraker is a
parody of a bond film moonraker has more
in common with austin powers than it
does
james bond that movie is
oh that is that is something else
i got sent two
terry pratchett novels the fifth
elephant
and feet of clay
uh both discworld and
i i am excited to get some more of that
i do i do have commissioned
uh reading to finish first
so i don't know when i'll get to these
uh including
a commissioned discworld novel so i'll
be getting more pratchett anyway which
will be nice
uh i'll see you cara
have a good have a good evening can you
hum you'll be back no
singing or whistling just humming i
don't know the the problem
is ms wicked wolf uh the problem is
i don't know exactly what it is that
sets off
the uh detection bots
to demonetize my stuff
so not knowing that i prefer not to push
it
uh what if aliens invaded the us but
they only abducted trump and his
supporters while the rest of the country
is perfectly fine
hmm i mean
broadly speaking i try i try really
really hard
to not wish ill
on people um even
like fantastical
um you know hypothetical
ill like that i i try really hard not to
do that and not
uh put that out into the universe if i
can help
it are you left or right handed
tell me what you think i am and we'll go
from there
spy who love me is miles better than
moonraker but drax is much better villa
villain than stromberg um that might be
true only insofar as i don't really
remember stromberg but i do remember
drax
i don't remember drax for any good
reasons but he's at least
more memorable
take my word for it return to oz is much
better than the black cauldron
that's not hard
the black cauldron is not
a good movie
at all it's actually one of the few that
i'd like disney to take a crack at
remaking
i prefer it stay animated but if i
wanted to go live action
um i i wouldn't i wouldn't moan too bad
because it's just not a good movie
you're ambidextrous is that your guess
hmm interesting
casino royale was so good i love it i
casino royale
is good
and also overrated like people fall over
themselves for that one i'm like ah
there's some big structural problems
with that movie
because it's not a movie it's three
movies it's three movies with three
separate climaxes
it's very bizarrely structured
is it possible for bond to become more
progressive i want franchises to do that
but bond is a drinking womanizing murder
he's kind of problematic by design yeah
the thing is i don't
know how much you can
update bond and still have it be
identifiable as
bond i mean at a certain point if you
change him too much then you might as
well have just created a new spy
character which
people are certainly within their rights
to do and plenty have
you know if you're gonna change him so
drastically that he's no longer
identifiable as james bond then
you might as well have not bothered
paying for the license and just come up
with your own
spy who uses gadgets and
you know and travels the world you know
the the the fundamentals of bond
once you remove the
the womanizing and the alcoholism
and the brutal murder
well like you could go to any number of
franchises for that you could make your
own very easy
so yeah i don't think you can i mean i
think the only
the only progressive option and i'm not
recommending this for the way
for for the way by the way excuse me
i tried to say both for the record and
by the way at the same time and ended up
with uh with whatever it is i said and i
can't remember now
but butts butts butts butt
uh bond is one of those characters that
really the only progressive thing to do
would be to stop making movies with him
but that'll never happen for as long as
he remains profitable
and i don't think that we need to cancel
james bond
yeah so you know it but
at a certain point the idea of making
bond more progressive
becomes self-defeating that said
there are ways to mitigate things there
are ways to address
the alcoholism and have it not to be as
glamorizing there are ways to have him
interact with these
gorgeous glamorous women that is not as
demeaning that is not
as exploitational there are ways to
still
have those things but just not be the
worst
version of them and i think that's kind
of the best bond is ever going to manage
to be
what do you think of vader's shards of
the past star wars
theory i don't know what that is
all hill council council of kings
council of the sith lords
ah my lightsaber's upstairs
nuts
excuse me
black widow looks far better than me
that no time to die i mean i hated
spectre so much
it's really hard for me to be excited
for
no time to die because i just
uh oh hi meg
i'm i am not as think as you drunk i am
uh if you want to read more pratchett i
recommend which is a board it's a fairy
tale parody deconstructs
generational bias and identity like
everybody has recommendations for
pratchett
45 minutes in and still articulate
youtube
cheeky meg cheeky discord thank you
carowind give me a second
ah so this is your reminder that
either either being a youtube member
or a patreon supporter
at a two dollar or higher tier
gets you um
access to the discord and other than
super chats that is the one way to
guarantee that i will read your comments
so let's see what we got
um i forgot what the clock's changing in
the u.s and not here i'll actually be
able to watch the stream tonight
yes because daylight savings is a
nightmare that
just haunts us all every year i probably
won't stay up too long so have you
thought of doing a ranking of
new who multi-part stories based on how
well
they stick the landing last episode
hmm idea from say live the land dropping
the ball uh
as to say the doctor dance is nailing it
special exclusion for hell bent to avoid
the last last rant um
it's it's an interesting way to
um it's an interesting lens through
which to look
at multi-part stories
is how consistent is the quality from
the first
second part part of what's interesting
about that is it
does not necessarily mean that the whole
thing is good
because i would actually argue that
something like say
the hungry earth and cold blood
the quality between those is very
consistent
it doesn't drop from one to the other
but overall it's not that good but it is
consistent in quality
so would you rank that higher than
something that either started
good and ended up a bit weaker but
whose good part was better than what
that two-parter is but
who's bad part is worse or vice versa
i don't know i'm not sure
i'm not sure i'd actually devote a whole
list to that
but it is an interesting way to to think
about
um the two-parters
i got one more kingsman to me is kind of
the upgraded james bond
uh also who are some villains you want
to see in the new batman franchise i'm
excited for riddler but poison ivy
desperately needs to
uh desperately
desperately needs an accurate adaptation
to film
the thing is we're never going to get a
good poison ivy until
batman as a film franchise is willing to
be a little bit
sillier because unless you're going to
integrate the fact that her kiss is
poison and she has some degree of
control over plants
then there's no point in doing her
because making her
realistic which for some reason all the
batman movies need to be
now even with a full reboot they still
need to be
realistic that that doesn't allow for
that
so until we get a version of batman on
film that is willing to be at least a
little
silly and indulge the more fantastical
elements of the source material
we're just never going to get a an iv
that's going to be any good
um as to
what villains i'd like to see uh in the
new batman franchise i think
my answer that's going to heavily depend
on what i think of the batman when it
comes out
what villains i'd want to see in that
world is largely going to depend on what
that world looks like if it looks the
way i think it looks
uh i'll just
i'll go with the vantrilloquist i keep
coming back to him
i like him sue me
uh finally the the notion that uh
kingsman is kind of an upgraded james
bond
kingsman is kind of kingsman is a bit of
a parody of bond it's just a
softer one it's not as
deliberately jokey as
something i obviously like say austin
powers but it is
sort of it's taking the piss
out of that template
um ooh super chat is that new did i
catch that ah
meg uh
[Music]
thank you meg are those lovely wavy
locks from braids that have been
released i'm guessing yes
yes this is this has been um my pattern
lately is
um i will shower i will put this in a
braid
and i will sleep in that and then the
next day i will take the braid out and
have
the waves
oh my gosh lily oh my goodness uh lily
marson
heart for you thank you very much
uh as soon as i get a job i'll join the
channel and patreon
but have this birthday gift for now what
are your thoughts on doctor who filming
in liverpool with catherine tate
sightings
and autons it's on my way home so i had
to peek
um i haven't dug too much into that
because
i try to avoid
spoilers and finding out
more about stuff like i generally don't
follow
you know leak i don't follow rumors if i
can help it
i don't follow leaked um pictures of
shooting or what have you
i did hear about katherine tate being
in the area that doesn't necessarily
mean
anything and that's a really good way to
get yourself worked up and
potentially disappointed because
you know there are many reasons why she
might be
in the area now if it is related to that
then the autons would be an odd
choice to pair with donna uh especially
because
where we left her she's still in a
position of
you know remembering anything related to
the doctor's gonna set
thing set bad things off so bringing up
uh an alien that she hasn't encountered
maybe makes sense but also like there's
no real connection between the two and i
would think if you were gonna bring her
back maybe something more
tied to her actual time as a companion i
have mixed feelings about the idea of
bringing donna back at all if i'm going
to be completely honest
and she is my favorite companion i love
donna noble
to death but we also had closure
i feel like the fan desire for
favorite characters to come back it's
very easy for that to
undo closure
and i think there's a lot of value in
closure
like we know donna's okay
and i think maybe that should be it
i actually enjoy daleks and manhattan
though uh its main flaws the doctor
doesn't need to be there
evolution dropped the ball dogs in
manhattan is a solid setup evolution of
the dogs is where everything falls apart
eventually it all comes back to doctor
who doesn't it
i love the way you hum okay
okay uh one thing i liked about zack
snyder's justice league they actually
credited jerry siegel and joe shuster
uh think about that these characters
have been around since
before world war ii they were credited
in the
theatrical version as well like legally
they have to be
that's not a something to give snyder
credit for
that's a legal issue warner brothers got
sued
over the fact that these guys weren't
getting credit and like it's
severe it's part of the reason that man
of steel
got made um in the time frame that it
did
because of the specifics of the
continued licensing deal
between uh the
estate of siegel the states of siegel
and shuster
and dc and warner brothers like
that they have to list them
so that's not a nod that's a legal
requirement
they've gotten bent over a barrel in
court already over that
i know final fantasy 6 is your all-time
favorite video game
uh what are some runners-up well i mean
being
being very much still into um
you know my time on 16-bit it would be
things like
secret of mana chrono trigger
um teenage mutant ninja for oh
god teenage mute
ninja turtles 4 turtles in
time
probably the most recent game that might
be in
consideration there is journey i did
like that one a lot
meg again thank you
thank you i really enjoyed the harley
quinn birds of prey movie i did too
have you heard anything about sequels
would love to see more from the same
director
it's really up in the air we'll get more
from
harley quinn they had because there was
another project being worked on called
gotham city sirens which is separate
from birds of prey
i think the idea
was to was to because traditionally the
birds of prey
have nothing to do with harley quinn
so i think the idea that they went in
with
was we'll use harley quinn to introduce
all these other characters
then send harley quinn off to do
something else and we'll have a
follow-up film with just these other
characters
i don't know if the movie did
well enough to
warrant that it didn't
bomb but it didn't perform what they
wanted
so there has at least last i checked
there's not been
firm word on a follow-up for that one
which is
really unfortunate
my buddy wrote a 11th and 11th doctor
story that took place at a mental
hospital where donna
was because she was going crazy from
glimpses of her time with the doctor
and mr finch ran it ah okay
thanks i hate it
don't put don in a mental no
i hate it no
no it's a good place for mr finch to be
but no
all right the bond dvds i have
pictures of bon on disc one and the
respective films bond lady on dis two
very telling that grace jones and sophie
marceau were chosen as the pictures
yeah that that uh that tracks you know
what's crazy marvel has versions of
classic movie monsters like dracula and
the wolf man but we haven't seen
anything
from them wtf marvel i mean that's not
surprising because
like that that was the kind of move that
made a lot of sense in comics
but in movies like anybody can make a
werewolf
or a dracula movie like i wouldn't be
shocked if we get something
along the lines of their versions of
dracula when we get whatever the heck
blade is going to be but other than that
they just don't have a lot of incentive
to go that way
thank you alexander
you get a heart just wanted to pop in
with a happy
belated birthday so happy belated
birthday
lovely uh let's see you don't do yoga
practice tai chi meditate practice
mindfulness
lift weights push-ups sit-ups what do
you do
i drink and i know things
i swear you set me up for that one
also five marvel movies this year yeah
which i'm a little
i'm a little iffy on i hope they don't
make that the standard but we'll see
you doubt that's water you impugn my
honor
how dare you scoundrel
scallywag it is not my responsibility
what filters be upon your screen
that taint this pure crystal clear
beverage
as some color that you presume to be
alcohol i bear no responsibility
for such illusions
i'll not have it
ray mazer thank you very much for the
super chat
forgive me for asking this oh dear but
i've known
how much this drama has hurt you but
have you heard about
finds his comments i personally think
he's trying to be non-committal but
uh it's not worth a dog pile yes
yes i did um
so i'm not gonna
i'm gonna try and not get into this too
much so ray finds who
played voldemort in the uh harry potter
franchise
he didn't voice specific support
for the ideas that jk rowling is putting
forth but he
did side with her insofar as
saying i don't think people should be
getting on her for having opinions
which means that he fails to
recognize that somebody like her
with the platform and the influence she
has it's not
just an opinion that somebody gets to
hold
it's actively damaging so the nicest
thing that i can say
about my opinion of ray finds right now
is he does not understand the impact
of what she's doing that is the nicest
thing that i can say
the uh harshest interpretation is that
he actually agrees with her but
recognizes that saying so would be a
very bad idea so he went halfway
i'm not prepared to go that far but i'm
just saying
the options aren't great so
meg big spender look at you coming back
again and again
nice to have regulars
you mentioned getting back into reading
if
you were going to buy and read a new
graphic novel
what do you think you'd gravitate
towards oh um
jeez i i
i want to get into more graphic novels
that aren't
uh superheroes i like superheroes
but like uh the thing about superhero
graphic novels is like they
unless you're really immersed in the
um universes that they take place in and
are prepared to keep
buying new like there's never any
closure in a superhero graphic novel
a volume always ends on resolve so that
you buy the next one
i i would like to
get into um graphic novels that
are in other genres like i i really
enjoyed
things like lumberjanes um
i didn't enjoy it because i hated one of
the characters but something like paper
girls or things that are completely
self-contained
i kind of just want to step outside of
superheroes
partly because i'm getting superheroes
from so many other mediums right now
i've got superheroes in film i've got
superheroes on television like
i can i pick up a graphic novel and get
something else
you know oh jack
thank you jack you get a heart
jack frederick since uh we've had the
irish let you struggle
i thought i'd go for the scottish side
oh god no
oh no that's not fair
ah so
jack has now put up happy birthday in
i can't even pronounce what dialect
you're saying that's
in oh my god that's
ah why am i buzzing that
oh why do i have that that should not be
getting alerts from that
anyways okay okay
oh i'm going to assume that's not
phonetic
mel dude hacked
i don't know
um
give me a panic attack with that one my
god
question have you seen marvel's dracula
if not
uh to me he looks awesome
but then i thought hobbs and shaw was
fun
uh no i have not i haven't logan
uh
have you seen any doctor whose stories
with vicky and if so what are your
thoughts on her i think she's so
underrated
i don't think so
i don't think so i mean by vicky do you
mean victoria
cause i've seen um
tombs of the cybermen but if vicky is
somebody other than that
then i don't know
recommend neverwhere by neil gaiman i've
read neverwhere that's my favorite book
from him
actually by the way
uh did you find me on tick tock yet um
i might have but then forgot so
i guess the answer is no then
new idea we should just pay vera to read
hard to pronounce words
i mean
i've done worse things for money
ah so all right couple more things
this this made me laugh my butt off
oh good trait tracy you get a heart
thank you so much tracy dale
happy belated birthday fun emojis yay
ending with glasses so i take that as a
cheers
very did well with the yiddish i mean
the only i like i can do a
sound decently so like that's the only
thing about me that
does decent yiddish vicky was
complaining to the first doctor
for a while after susan left nope don't
know her
um so
in a video i made a month ago two months
ago when i made a video
talking about whether or not artists
should be allowed to keep
messing with their art once it's out
there and obviously i brought up
director's cuts and one of the things i
mentioned in there was my
eternal frustration with the fact that
the only version of the last of the
mohicans that you can get is the
director's cut which i don't like
because
the ending completely loses its sense of
pace it just peters out because it just
goes on too long
so somebody
they they went and found you got because
apparently the only place you can get
the theatrical cut
is on the vhs so not only
did this person find the vhs
they also
scanned the vhs to a dvd
that that tickled me
to no end on your last name video i said
sasa la bacon
oh maybe i'll remember to check that
um
at least we can now say uh
it's the only person defending you is
voldemort not a good sign
i mean yeah there's that i recently
watched your piece on separating the art
from artists and i was wondering how do
you feel about authors writing stories
in another's world like gaiman doing
lovecraft
um my general opinion of that
has it's a very case-by-case thing
um because like lovecraft is an
aw is actually an awkward one to kind of
talk about
when you talk about his influence and
people doing things with him now
because while i think there's a lot of
issues with the man's actual work
because
his racism and his fear around
basically anyone who didn't look like
him
is very baked into those stories and you
can't really separate
the work from that
the thing is his works in the public
domain it has been for a while which
means
literally anyone can take his ideas
his concepts his mythos and
weave something new out of it and i
would absolutely say
go nuts by all means
when a when something's in public domain
have at it when it is still
under some kind of copyright um it gets
weirder for me and like i said it
becomes very much a case-by-case basis
so like for example
it's not as good as most of the others
but
i did enjoy um the additional book that
was written
to be part of the hitchhiker's guide to
the galaxy series it was called um
and another thing and
i cannot remember the name of the person
who wrote it
same person who wrote um artemis fowl
uh ian colfer i think
um but yeah i was okay with that because
i read it and it did
honor the voice of douglas adams
and um you know and it felt
that that felt okay but like a lot of
times cases like that if it is still
under some kind of copyright it's just a
way to keep the ip alive and
for generally a corporation to make
money off it and yeah my supporter
for that is limited so lovecraft is
always kind of a weird one to talk about
because he's an exception to a lot of
the things that are in play when you
talk about
others um
of that nature um anything that is newer
than that
so like when you talk lovecraft when you
talk sherlock holmes there's a lot more
wiggle room
oh jimmy jonathan lee
you get a heart thank you very very much
with the polarized reaction to directors
with unique visions
like snyder or ryan johnson with big
franchises
do you think fans are too attached
no because in both cases i can
fundamentally understand
why the fans went went and rejected what
they did
i and and in both cases it does not
feel petty to me i mean some people will
be petty about it
but overall it doesn't feel to me like
people are just like this is different
and therefore bad
because i mean christopher nolan was
different and it wasn't bad
tim burton was different it wasn't bad
well
first one wasn't bad so i don't think
and it's
i i don't think it is as simple as
you did unique thing therefore bad
i think there were specific things about
the choices that
snyder and johnson made that
rubbed certain sections of fandom the
wrong way and i think
it's an understandable reaction in both
cases at least to a certain degree now
understand when i say understandable i
don't mean the behaviors of some fans
either uh against or in favor of either
of those things those can still go way
off the way
way off the rails but in terms of like
just having that reaction no
i think it's uh fairly understandable
honestly so
i mean that that is the risk that you
run when you
get somebody who is more of an auteur
and grant him
more autonomy to project his style onto
these things
whether or not that works depends
entirely
on whether their auteur style and
sensibilities
are going to be a good match for the
material and if the answer is yes
you'll get something that is different
but in a way that fans will love and
embrace
again batman begins dark knight
really good examples of that but if it
clashes
then fans are gonna call
call that out they just are
black widow is gonna be on disney plus
what are your thoughts i'm
gonna watch it on disney plus i mean
that's
that's my thoughts i'm not going to a
theater
not till i don't know
not for a while i watched the
oscar-nominated mateo
garone film of pinocchio this week the
makeup work is
incredibly good and shows to disney
that they don't really need to do
horrific cgi
huh i don't know anything about that one
thanks again for the chat everyone see
you in the next live chat up have you
been drinking as well meg
have a good night
uh if you're going to remake the haunted
mansion
and they casted you in would you do it
i mean i don't have a career so yes if
they cast me in a major
film unless it was something that i
thought was
morally abhorrent yeah of course i would
there really isn't much of a story to
tell with the haunted mansion though
and i love the haunted mansion i love
the ride i love the record
but like there just isn't it's a tour
it's it's a tour through ghosts that are
here so i mean what are your options
you either tell the stories behind
these ghosts there's so many of them
you'd have to pick only one or two and
honestly none of their stories are
interesting enough to hold a movie
or you tell the stories of someone who
came into the haunted mansion
and then you've basically just got the
record and how do you make it
more than just a walking tour of
ghost rooms like we with something like
pirates of the caribbean you could just
take the aesthetics and a couple of
things about it and just slap it onto
a otherwise just like just do a pirate
story
you can't just do a haunted house story
if it's gonna be disney's the haunted
mansion because just doing a haunted
house story means
being legitimately creepy and part of
the appeal of the haunted house is that
it is creepy but safe it's creepy but
playful
and i don't think there's a way to get
an interesting movie story out of that i
just
don't
i'm gonna wrap it up soon i think
remember only not yes ben i remember
have you seen the old guard yes ben i
have
i believe i have a review up in the
break room for the old guard so
go take a look at that old bean what oh
pip pip
was that offensive i don't know
i hope not
my heritage is english if that helps
check out in defense of hp lovecraft by
weaponized nerd rage it's a great video
that actually goes into his life and
background
i'll add it to the to-do list no promise
on when i'll get to it
sexy and you know what darn right
i've got a couple of other things to
show you before i go
this i will be curious
how many people recognize this and know
what this is
but this uh was something that
uh liz um
liz decided that i should have this and
commissioned one of our friends to make
it
so i will be curious as to who can
identify
this fellow
this this newest addition to my stuffed
animal collection
and while i wait to see your answers on
that do you know what classic doctor
whose story you plan on reviewing on
your channel next nope i need to put a
poll to the
uh to the patreon for that
bibo from legends of tomorrow well
well done you folks do not disappoint me
he is bebo god of war people
want cuddles
oh no no one says pit pip oh
try and remember that one
that's clearly elmo get out
my prediction for the disney pinocchio
remake is there's
uh is there is no way
going to have all the kids trapped as
donkeys
yeah i expect they'll soften that give
me a piece of that cake get your own
cake
uh um
so a couple of other things
this next thing this
uh this is actually this wasn't a gift
uh i had enough people send me
like gift cards uh for amazon and things
like that
that um i made the decision to
spend that on
um on cosplay items because i haven't
indulged myself by getting new cosplay
in a while
and the first couple of things
um relating to that have come in i don't
have the full thing yet
but the rest is coming so
this is my t's we'll see
if people identify
this cosplay would be
of course the problem is the problem is
with these on i can't read
the chat anymore because these aren't
prescription
didn't you have a flaming sword yeah you
did it was flaming like anything what
happened to it
all right let me actually be able to see
now
uh if the muppet show ever got a reboot
you should guest star i would be happy
to
crowley crowley yep yep yep
yep people got it crowley
i am uh i'm excited for that
i've got uh i've got a i've got a coat
coming in and i've got a wig coming in
uh it'll be interesting to try and stuff
all this
up uh under it but yep
so and that that's not the only cosplay
thing i have coming
in but it is the only thing i've started
to get um
bits in for the other the other one is
um it's a bit more niche
but was actually really cheap to put
together
and is for a movie that i absolutely
love
and is one of those cases of i don't
care if people get it i'm just gonna do
it
um but i'll leave you hanging uh to
wonder what that would be
do you ever cosplay someone from glee no
i have a soul
i'm sorry that was cruel uh david
tennant always plays characters with
great looks even kill grave
kilgrave did have a good look
uh the coachman from the 1941 scared me
as a kid
yep now that is uh that is fair when it
comes to pinocchio
i'm looking for a good response to
someone who steadfastly believes gender
is genetic
would family be good comparison or
would come off as claiming trans are
honorary or something by the way hello
hello
black cover um
well it sounds to me
like you've got a you've got a barrier
you have to overcome
before you can even tackle that
because having that position probably
means that they are equating
gender with sex in the first place
so if they believe those to be
synonymous and the exact same thing
that's a hurdle you've got to overcome
before you can even really start
tackling the idea that
gender is in your genes because the
honest truth
is gender
may be genetic we don't know
we don't know enough about
what factors control what factors if any
contribute to the gender identity that
one
has so
the issue is not that he believes that
gender is genetic
because like i said it might be
i don't believe that it is but it's
possible
and believing that gender is in some way
genetic
that there is something in your
hereditary line that would make you more
inclined to
be transgender fluid non-binary
that in and of itself as a belief is not
a problem
the problem is
if that belief stands on top of a belief
that gender is only the two options
and that and that therefore
is determined by your chromosomes and
that's what they mean by saying that
gender is gin
is genetic so exactly how you pull that
apart
depends on the specifics of what it is
they actually believe
that is underneath that because as i
said that
supposition in and of itself gender is
genetic
need not actually be a problem provided
it allows for the acknowledgement of
genders
outside of male female and
you are and whatever you are assigned to
birth is immutable
that's actually a completely separate
issue from believing that gender is in
some way genetic
hope that made sense but there we go
um ah
damn it i went to reach for the glass
and it's it's empty that really is my
sign
are you cosplaying franklin jealous
skeletor if i
if i had the capability to do that
makeup i would do it in a heartbeat but
yeah i
i am uh i can't
have to go to school unfortunately wish
me luck on my philosophy exam
best of luck gray
uh gender binary nature nurture
nonsense
[Laughter]
yeah but like the the thing is it i'm
actually kind of glad you asked because
it is one of the things that we don't
always
think about that sometimes
these things that get said that
you know things like gender is genetic
as broad concepts aren't the issue
it's whatever underlying assumptions
they are sitting on top of
that make them an issue which
i think is it's an important thing to
realize and distinguish because
if you're going to try and address it
you need to attack the underlying root
issues that make
that belief a problem because if you
could change the foundational
assumptions that
someone is making then the surface level
arguments
will fix themselves
it has to be the core things that we
deal with that we address
that we when necessary
attack it needs to be those core
concepts that
poison everything that gets laid over
them
as opposed to playing whack-a-mole with
the beliefs that get stacked on top of
that because
and like i don't i i don't know your
friend i don't know
if i've made the correct assumptions
about him but for the moment
if i have then that means
that if his base assumptions are there
are only two genders
and those are immutable chain
unchangeable facts
tied to your dna and assigned at birth
then whatever rationalization he's
offering
such as gender is genetic you give him a
reason to not believe that
he'll find a new set of beliefs to lay
on top of his base assumptions
until you change those base assumptions
he'll just
keep swapping out and finding new
rationalizations to not change the base
assumptions
and you're just playing whack-a-mole
with rationalizations
and you never get anywhere doing that
you gotta go for the sweep the leg
listen to sensei crease sweep the leg
do you have a problem with that
no mercy
date myself with that reference although
not as much now i suppose cobra kai put
it back in the uh
in the popular imagination i actually i
got to take these off that's starting to
uh that's starting to pinch my ear
ah i like these earrings but they are
they are a lot
uh
oh there we go
i'm a cis straight woman and gender is
confusing because i know i'm a woman and
i like it but i never really
felt super attached to the idea of being
a woman because i'm a gender
non-conforming woman
what what can be confusing for
um a lot of people
who who themselves are cisgender
especially if they're cisgender people
who
understand that a lot of what we
ascribe as gender markers are
performative
and not immutable to a gender you know
things like
makeup hair length fashion sense
there's nothing actually intrinsic about
women that would incline them to wear
dresses or men to wear trousers that's
completely societal
so if you understand that much
trans or gender non-conforming people
who
don't identify as cis can
make things confusing because from the
outside looking in
it can appear as though we are
through our actions and like so with
someone like me
by connecting more to my femininity with
makeup nail polish
it may seem like i'm projecting this
idea or that i'm pushing this idea that
this is what femininity is
and i don't believe that i do these
things because they make me feel good
and there have been times where they
have helped
connect me more to my own femininity
these are not my femininity
but they are a means to
feel it more strongly sometimes
not always like the makeup still the
nails
actually not really the nails have just
been a default for so long that's that's
that's
just me like i don't ascribe any gender
markers to the nails at this point
but i do still to make up and i do to
the hair
but they are they are a means for me to
connect
and it is not that this
is being female it's that this
helps me feel like myself
so again there's a lot of
weird ins and outs and eccentricities
and things that are really specific
to the people who
you're dealing with and i have now gone
way over
when i said i would wrap up um
excuse me the thing about lots of these
people
is they are bad at stepping outside of
themselves
my dad before i came out couldn't
understand being bi
because he couldn't envision himself as
bi that
yeah like that is
um that is a big part of the problem for
a lot of people i mean it's a it's
and it's it's why
it's why it's so important
to listen and believe people when they
tell you
their own experience especially if it is
based on life experience that is
different from yours
it is why it is that it's why it should
frankly be a
crime that rooms
full of men legislate
women's bodies
because they that they do not
and will not and will never understand
that experience
at best they don't understand it at
worst they don't
value it because they don't understand
it
no matter how empathetic you are
there is only so much that you can
do to truly project yourself and
understand
someone who just has a different
life experience and view of the world
than you do
there's only so much you can do
which is why no matter how empathetic
you are
no matter how thoughtful you
think you are how well you think you
understand something you we have to let
people be in the room to make the
decisions about
their own things that will affect their
lives
it's why there have to be women
in in the room when we legislate women's
right it's why there has to be lgbtq
plus people
when questions of whether or not to
restrict their rights they need to be
and they're not and not just like
bring some in to testify like no they
need to be involved
with the law making because for so many
people
if they cannot wrap their head around it
then as far as they're concerned it's
not even a real thing
or if it is it's not worth worrying
about
no matter who you are there are limits
to human empathy there is a limit to
how much or how well
you are ever going to be able to
understand someone else
that there just is
connor thank you very much for the super
chat connor johnson
have you seen the 2015 thriller green
room i have
it's pretty good it's brutal that one
um would you say sexuality in practice
is more nebulous than the labels would
suggest oh yeah
oh yeah absolutely like
labels for me in a lot of ways are
more trouble than they're worth um
but like there is there's some value in
labels in that
sometimes you need the shorthand because
you're never going to
um really truly get to know somebody as
well as you would in a one-on-one basis
to be able to understand them sans
labels
so labels are a shortcut
to basically say well i'm basically this
but they're also a problem because when
we place too much value on the labels it
means that we
do not properly comprehend
how much people deviate from those
labels or fall between those labels or
there is no label for them
and you know we just assume that we hear
this label like oh well that's
definitely what they are like no
that's the shortcut that they're trying
that they gave you so you can try and
get a general sense of them
i think that's the case definitely with
gender and possibly even more so with
sexuality because
like the idea of
gay straight bi pan asexual
even beyond that you know there's
um you'll you'll run into terms in
certain communities with things like
heteroflexible
or homoflexible someone you know some
home someone who
is um heteroflexible
is primarily heterosexual
but is open to or on rare occasions does
indulge in
homosexual activities basically trying
to find a label for someone who
is close enough to straight
that bisexual doesn't feel right because
when people here buy they tend to think
50 50 split which is almost never the
case anyways but that's a whole other
thing
and you know try and find a way to find
a term that falls in between that and
that's the thing with labels they either
they either are so broad to be unhelpful
or they get so specific
that it gets overwhelming trying to keep
track of them all that's sort of where i
get annoyed with them i need to stop i
need to stop i need to stop looking at
the chat
i have work to do i need to shoot stuff
because i got to edit tomorrow
because i got like i i've i'm i got a
lot i've got a lot this week a lot a lot
a lot so i got to stop
um so
and there goes the super chat chris
thank you chris mcgovern thank you so
much nathaniel i recently came out
myself
and it's so true that makeup and nails
help certainly me
to help feel and true to help feel
happier and truer to self
happy birthday to you as well thank you
chris
thank you so
um thank you everybody for tuning in
these have been going longer lately i
used to reliably keep them to an hour
they seem to be creeping up to an hour
and a half i'm not gonna make a promise
that that becomes
a thing but uh
you know that's been the trend is it a
burden to be the ambassador
um sometimes
sometimes it's a privilege
thanks very much for watching everybody
i hope you have a wonderful rest of the
week stay
safe take care of each other
take care of yourself and please
remember
that you are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved you are the council
and i am just running the meetings and
until next time this council
is adjourned mccabe